but better than 30 points hookers corner
all there is not a strip downtown
what's a
we took the first swing
[Applause]
that's what sell to my lovely cousin
called husband
look like there's a file down below once
this shot was made
[Applause]
again we gave him beat a shot to the
back there and B toss the ball letting
it in let so return the favor
there was a fat camper yeah more like a
breaking ball I was a breaking ball from
the beat and then Eric I think delivered
the fastball there for the strike this
has got to in quickly though to make
sure it didn't escalate it I'll be
interested to see how they I would
assume you go a double tech here I would
think so I don't know how they will make
the judgment on that well that the issue
is are they gonna look at because they
they blew the whistle they blew the
whistle and Glen so gave a little shove
to the back there and then indeed toss
the ball and it is let so tossed it back
so it's Mike Scott I think toss the ball
in there as well so or it could be a
flagrant that would mean unnecessary
contact of the judgment of the official
pushed him off a little bit and you
could see
let's--oh not having any of it oh you
know what though and that Mike Scott
what to get it
[Music]
- tension mm let's
[Music]
[Applause]
and you know Mike Budenholzer rust out
there and tried to corral here
[Applause]
there were fluent elite epiphysis coming
over to explain the call
[Music]
so